TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
let's get this party
started, shall we?
This is the Advanced Google+
History session.
Thank you so much for coming.
Only the hardcore make it this
far, and I appreciate every
single one of you.
Hi, I'm Timothy.
I'll be your developer advocate
for the next hour.
And we're going to go through
a whole bunch of really
interesting topics.
And it's all going to center
around this one big thing that
we just launched recently.
Now, it's an early developer
preview.
So it's the time for us to
experiment with it and get
ready for a user launch.
And for those of you-- and
I'm going to do some
recap at the beginning.
I just want to get an idea of
who was at the Google+ History
session this morning.
All right, so about
half of you.
Great.
So I'm going to go through
this review quickly.
This is the idea.
Instant upload is cool.
I take pictures with my phone.
And they get uploaded
to Google+.
I can go back and look at them
any time that I want.
And for those that I want to
share, I get to choose to
share them to my friends,
my family, or public.
All right?
And it's this save privately
and optionally share action
that we're using for other
activities on the web.
And this is where you come in.
You write moments into Google.
And it shows up for that user
in their private area.
And then they can choose
to share those
out by making a post.
This is all about getting your
content in more places.
Let's take a quick look at a
demo to see this in action.
All right, so I am going
to-- let's see here.
I want this window and
these buttons.
Here we are.
So we had the opportunity to
work with Last.fm to play with
this API before releasing it.
And they've been really great
about telling us where our
bugs were and testing
things out.
Now, if you're not familiar
with Last.fm, it's a great
product that allows you--
they call it scrobbling.
They remember the music
that you play from
wherever you hear it.
And then they use that data to
recommend additional music and
concerts to you.
And because of these reasons,
we think it's a really good
match for Google+ History.
I'll show you how it works
on Last.fm here.
So this is the test page
that they set up
with a Sign In button.
I'm going to click
this button.
And I get a permissions
dialogue.
Now, I'm granting Last.fm
permission for two things.
One, my Google+ ID, and the
ability to write into my
Google+ History.
I'll go ahead and hit Connect.
Now, what's happening right now
is it's going through the
second part of the
OAuth process.
And Last.fm just got
my credentials.
So now the next thing I
want to do is perform
some sort of activity.
So I think I'll jump
over to Radio.
And my buddy Ade recommended
a band to me
just the other day--
Stereo 360.
Let's load that up.
All right.
So this is playing now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
there we are.
So this is the Last.fm that
you're familiar with--
going on there and listening
to music and
discovering new music.
By adding Google+ History, the
next thing that we have here
is I can now go over to Google+
into this developer UI
that you see.
If I reload the page, there's
a new moment--
Listened to California.
And I want to mention a couple
things about this.
First off, you see some
album art there.
And we're pulling this
from the target URL.
And I'm going to talk more about
that in some detail in
the session.
You also see Last.fm's logo
and the actual activity--
Listened to California.
Now, if I click on California,
it's going to take
me to the song page.
And I can download, or
I can listen again.
So far, even before sharing,
we've seen the value for the
user here is this huge
nostalgia thing--
being able to go back to their
Google+ History and see what
tracks they listened
to yesterday, last
week, or last month.
Now the next step is, if they do
want to make a post out of
this, they can hover over
that moment and
click the Share button.
And they can share with their
friends, or their family, or
the public using the
power of Circles.
I'm going to share
it back with Ade.
I'll go ahead and click Share.
And I've created a post.
Just see what that looks like.
You'll notice a couple
things here.
First off, there's the album.
And there's the attribution
to Last.fm, right
there at the top--
Listened on Last.fm.
And then below, of course,
is the link to the song.
This is Google+ History.
We've seen a simple OAuth
process, and then the ability
to share moments privately, and
then optionally post them.
All right.
I'm going to go ahead and
turn off that song.
Very good.
Cool.
So that's History.
And we went over all the basics
in the first session,
Getting Started with
Google+ History.
In this session, I'm going to
cover some advanced topics.
We're going to go in depth with
a number of things and
take a look at some extra stuff
that you can do, both on
mobile and using the Sign
In button to do some
authentication for login.
Let's review the overall
process.
First, you set up your
application.
And to do that, you use
the API console.
Next, you authorize the
user using OAuth 2.
And third, you write moments.
These are all technologies that
you're likely already
familiar with.
And let me just get
a survey there.
Who's been to or knows about
our API console?
Great, several of you.
For those of you haven't, it's
developers.google.com/console.
It's how you create
an application and
add services to it.
So you can actually
access our API.
Who's used OAuth 2?
All right, so a lot of us.
And who's used our
RESTful API?
All based on that,
super easy to do.
This is what the flow
looks like.
You initiate the OAuth flow.
And then the user gets the
permissions dialogue.
And they say, yes, I would
love to connect.
And then we send the user
through a client-side or a
server-side flow.
And then we're done.
Next step is, in the
background, you
start writing moments.
There's a Write in which you
send some JSON to Google,
identifying the activity.
And then there's a Fetch.
And this is the point at which
Google grabs the target URL,
learns about it, and then knows
how to display that
moment in Google+.
Let's look at this
in some depth.
This is the process from
start to finish.
There's an activity
on Last.fm--
listening to this radio
station, in
particular, this song--
with the result all the way on
the other side of having a
moment in Google+ History.
The first step, as
I mentioned, is
writing that activity.
And this is the list of
activities that you can write.
We want help on this.
This is one of the reasons we've
got a developer preview,
is that here's a
list of verbs--
of activities on your site--
that we think are going to be
common and you're going to want
to write into Google+.
But there's going
to be others.
Yeah?
And for the time being, you
can use one of the generic
verbs, such as AddActivity.
When something else doesn't fit,
AddActivity's a good one.
For all sorts of creations,
CreateActivity's a good one.
But if you can be specific,
like a purchase, use the
BuyActivity.
And if there's an activity that
you think is going to be
common, but it's not on this
list, let us know.
We have an issue tracker
that's linked off the
documentation.
Now, the activity
looks like this.
You have a type and a target.
This is the first one we're
going to look at.
This is a ListenActivity.
The type is the activity that
was performed, in this case
ListenActivity.
And the target is the item
that it was performed on.
In this case, it's a song.
Here's a CommentActivity.
And I'm going to add
a new section here.
We have the type and the target
as before, but now we
also have a result.
And this is because I've
written a comment.
And now a comment exists
out in the world.
It's a result of the activity.
So that result will include
the type, in this case, a
comment; the permalink to that
comment; and then the text of
the comment.
Now, these fields are going to
differ depending on what
you're creating.
And we have a reference for
that in the documentation.
And that's the difference
between these two kinds of
activities.
There's those that have a result
and those that don't
have a result.
After you write the activity,
there's a Fetch step, which is
how we get the information to
render the moment and a post,
if the user makes it.
Now, who's familiar with this
process for when users just
share on Google+, how we
construct this using
schema.org?
So a handful of us.
For the rest of you, the way
this works is that you mark up
your page, indicating
what you want to be
displayed for these.
And then we respect that.
You use schema.org markup to do
so, and it looks like this.
Now, this is a music
recording.
And you'll see up at
the top, we have
itemscope and itemtype.
And then we have itemprops--
name, description, image.
And then we have a sub
itemtype below that.
And this is microdata markup.
It's the HTML5 spec.
Schema.org uses that spec with
its own activity types and
property names.
Let's take a look at
another one here.
Here's that CommentActivity.
And this is BlogPosting.
We have itemscope up there
and itemprops--
URL, name, and description.
Now, a couple key things here--
and I'll reiterate
these from the Getting
Started session--
is that you don't have to add
any new content to your site.
Most of the time, all the
content that you need is
already in the page.
You just have to mark
up what's there.
You have to indicate
what's there.
And the other thing is that
this isn't visible to the
user, whether you have
the markup or not.
So you're not changing
how your page
appears on a website.
You're just marking
it up for Google.
Real quick--
itemscope is going to be
on the parent tag.
And the itemtype is the
type of an item.
All below there is where we'll
look for itemprops that
correspond to that type.
And then each of these itemprops
indicate the
properties of this item.
In this case, you see a URL, you
see a name, and you'd see
a description.
OK.
Let's take a look at some these
in practice, shall we?
All right.
So this is our Google+ History
API starter, and it does some
pretty cool things.
Once I sign in, it gives me
this UI that lets me write
some canonical moments.
These are example moments.
And we're hosting the
target URLs on our
documentation site.
So let's just write
some of these.
How about a BuyActivity, a
CommentActivity, and a
CheckInActivity?
I'll go over to my Google+
History and reload.
And there we have them.
So here's the BuyActivity
and the CommentActivity.
Let's see if the CheckInActivity
will show up.
There's the CheckInActivity.
Now, you'll notice each
of these has--
it's a rich moment.
We can tell by looking
at it what it is.
Let's click through
to one of these--
Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland.
Very simple page-- you can see
us on our documentation site.
And if you want, you can-- let's
see if I can do this on
this keyboard.
There we are.
You can take a look
at the source.
And you'll see the schema.org
markup right up
there on the page.
This is a great opportunity to
look at all the activity types
that we have, find the ones that
you're going to use, and
look up how we actually
communicate these and how we
mark them up.
And one other thing to note
down here is that--
so that you see the markup,
as far as the payload--
what you send--
it's actually printed down
here in this box.
So you'll see Sending moment.
And there's the BuyActivity
right there
with the target URL.
So start to finish, you can see
the code for some of these
canonical moments.
All right, what's next?
Straight to OAuth.
Now I'm going to be bouncing
around a lot, because these
are just advanced topics.
There's no real order here.
This is one topic I wanted
to cover briefly.
We put together this Sign
In button also in
the developer preview.
Because we think it's a good
idea to have a button that
users are going to recognize
on websites to sign in with
Google+, but also to make
it really easy to
start the OAuth process.
However, there's times that
you're going to want to start
the OAuth process
your own way.
Maybe you want to do
this because you
want to do it in flow--
the user signing up
to your website
through your own system.
And you just want to authorize
at the same time.
Now to do that, you can initiate
the OAuth flow like
you would any other
OAuth flow.
It's OAuth 2.
It's a standard.
And it's just this step right
here at the beginning.
Now, I'm going to show you some
code for starting this
with the JavaScript
client library.
And I'll give you a brief peek
at some of the languages.
And I use the client library,
because starting OAuth without
a client library is
much more painful.
In fact, just a show of hands--
who's used OAuth before?
Right.
And keep those hands up.
Who of you have started the
OAuth process manually,
without a client library?
OK.
Keep your hands up if you
enjoyed the process.
Ade, you are the only one.
[? AUDIENCE: He's lying. ?]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: He
probably is.
So the thing is, these client
libraries just automate a lot
of the issues for you, and just
get that OAuth process
standing up without
too much work.
And this is what it looks
like in JavaScript.
And you'll see--
really straightforward.
First, we include the
client library.
In JavaScript, we just have
to include the JS.
Then we have a method that
does some initialization.
In this case, we're telling the
Google client library what
API we want to use and
what our API key is.
Next, we have a button that when
you click it, we initiate
the OAuth process.
And all you got to do
here is pass the
client ID and the scope.
And then finally,
we authorize.
Now this is really simple, for
those of you that have seen
the manual process versus
the client library.
And it's available in
multiple languages--
PHP and Python.
In fact, we have a whole
list of them.
Check out the client library.
And if you do it, this is
the best way to do it.
If you do need to do it
manually, we do have
documentation.
Make sure to pour yourself a cup
of coffee and sit down for
a good read.
All right, Error Handling--
another topic.
I'm going to show you
a lot of errors.
And it can look kind
of daunting.
But there's only a couple that
you really have to pay
attention to.
I want to cover them so you know
the kinds of things that
can go wrong and get an
idea of what you might
be looking out for.
But again, there's only a couple
that you're going to
encounter commonly.
They're going to occur
in a couple areas.
I'm going to cover first the
authorization process.
And then I'm going to look
briefly at writing moments.
For the authorization process,
you can see them after
initializing OAuth.
And you can see them after the
user has gone through the
permissions dialogue.
So let's take the first one,
right after initializing the
OAuth flow or while
trying to do so.
You're going to see a couple
different kinds of these
button errors.
You're going to see missing,
malformed, or invalid data.
And this could be an invalid
callback parameter, an invalid
scope, or an invalid clientid.
You might also see not defined
or unmatching errors.
And I put up this list.
You can look deeper at these
slides later when
we post them online.
The other set of errors that
you'll see are after the
permissions dialogue, when
you're entering into either
the client-side or the
server-side flows.
And this is the whole
list of errors.
Again, this is part
of the standard.
And all of these are important
to have a rough idea about at
the very least.
But there's one that you're
going to get commonly--
hopefully, not too commonly.
This is when the user
sees the permissions
dialogue and says, no.
At that point, you're going to
want to do something, like ask
them why, or say, please,
try again.
But you do want to
handle this one.
Because you're going to handle
that a little bit differently
than if it's a server-side error
that you need to fix,
that you need manual
intervention.
And this is what it will look
like on the client side.
So I've written a function
here for
the client-side callback.
And a parameter is
passed to this.
I've called it event here,
and I'm looking
for property error.
If there is an error,
this will be set.
If it's not an error, it
just won't be set.
And I'm throwing in a switch
statement here.
You can do an if.
Whatever it is, you're just
looking for that Access
Denied, asking why they don't
like you, and then moving on.
However, if there's no error,
all you're doing
is hiding the button.
Everything worked perfectly.
This should be the
common case.
For the server side, same set
of errors, you just get to
them in a different place.
Instead of not setting that
property on the parameter we
passed to the callback, we won't
set the parameter on the
URL, if there's no errors.
If there is, we will.
So you need to grab that
from the request.
And if it's there, you
handle the error.
Again, same set of errors.
And then we have errors here.
We write a moment to Google.
And then we fetch
the target URL.
And there's one that I'm going
to look at, and that's a
missing metadata field.
So let's actually look
at these in practice.
No session is complete without
a demo where you at least
break one thing.
So I purposely broke
some things.
Now, this is the History
API starter again.
And I've got a couple versions
of this doing
things that are wrong.
The first one is the missing
clientid parameter.
And you will typically see this
printed out on the console--
this particular error.
In this case, I'm just pushing
it into the browser here, on
the actual page.
So you'll notice two things--
you'll see the error
down here.
And you'll also notice
there is no button.
That is as intended.
The next error I wanted
to show you is
the malformed clientid.
In this case, I put in, "My
voice is my passport, verify
me." And it didn't work.
So again, it's not showing
the button.
And it's telling me
what's going on.
And this one, I want to show
you what happens if I
disapprove.
I'm going to click Sign On, hit
Cancel, and there we are--
Access Denied.
This one is bad metadata.
So let me go ahead
and sign in.
I actually have some canned
bad metadata here.
In this API starter, you can
write a custom moment.
I'm going to paste
it in right here.
And this is actually pointing to
a URL that we'll look at in
a moment that has
bad metadata.
We'll go ahead and write
this moment.
And you'll see we
get a response--
missing metadata field,
the name.
So we've looked at the errors
that come from the button.
And we've looked at the errors
that come after the
permissions dialogue.
And this is--
after you do the OAuth process,
you're writing moments--
the errors that you
get at this point.
And in fact, if you have
incorrect metadata, oftentimes
we'll be able to give you
an error message.
In this particular page,
it looks like this.
I'm specifying a schema.org
thing type.
And I've got no itemprops.
Name is a required field.
It's missing.
And we throw an error.
There's a couple more topics
that I want to talk about.
First, starting with mobile.
Now, who did see the
mobile session?
So a few of you.
I'm going to just review
a little bit of mobile.
It looks like what we saw
before, where you set up your
application, you authorize the
user, and you write moments.
But instead of using just the
API console, OAuth 2, and REST
API, we're going to use
these new things.
In the API console, we need
to specify an installed
application, in this case,
an Android application.
I'm going to talk about Android
specifically, though,
coming soon, this will
work for iOS as well.
And then you need to give it
your SHA-1 fingerprint.
And this is how we're able to
both associate and verify the
application that you are
building an APK for--
and the app that you've defined
in the API console.
It looks like this.
Instead of choosing a web
application, we're choosing an
installed application.
And then we're setting the
package name and the SHA-1
fingerprint.
Next, we want to initialize
the client and the OAuth
device flow.
And we do that in code
in the application.
And finally, on Android, to
submit a moment, you just fire
up an intent and use that
to submit a moment.
Now for more information or a
look at this code, you should
go to the Integrating Google+
into Mobile Apps session.
You can find that
on that link.
But I want to take a look at the
application just to give
you a brief taste of what
it will look like.
So let us switch to,
I think, this one.
There we are.
Works like a charm.
I've got a couple applications
here I'm going to show you.
This is the first one
for this section.
And this is a general Google+
SDK sample application.
You can download this, set up
your application, put in your
SHA-1 fingerprint, compile,
and run this.
And it'll just work.
I'm going to sign in.
And it's going to ask which
account did I want to use.
And I'm signed in.
Oh, look, it has my name.
That's cool.
So let's go back here.
And let's just submit
a couple moments.
What haven't I done yet?
Let's try a ListenActivity,
and maybe a ViewActivity.
So switching back over to here
to take a look at that.
[INAUDIBLE]
Here we are, back
on the computer.
And you can see we've got
a ViewActivity and a
ListenActivity coming from
the mobile device.
Pretty cool, right?
All right, switching back to
the presentation here.
One more thing I want to
talk about is login.
I think there's a hidden gem in
here for using the Sign In
button, which gives you
an OAuth 2 flow for
login across platforms.
Now, this is the flow that we
saw earlier where you initiate
the OAuth flow, then you get the
permissions dialogue, and
then you do client-side
or server-side.
And then you're done.
But that permissions dialogue,
if you've already authorized,
just bounces back some
credentials.
It's login.
The user's already logged
into the Google account.
They hit that button, and you
know who they are-- that
particular user in that
particular browser.
All you need to do is
keep that Google+
ID somewhere safe.
And you can find that in here.
This is the OAuth 2 response.
And inside it are an access
token, and token type, when it
expires and created, and an
ID token right there.
Now the ID token--
it's a web-safe, Base64-encoded,
and it
contains a few fields.
There's a lot of interesting
stuff in here,
if you take a look.
It's a JSON web token, if you're
familiar with JWT.
But there's one thing in
particular that I'm going to
be interested in.
It's this ID.
So for this example, I'm
just grabbing this ID.
That said, if you're actually
doing this flow, you want to
verify the signature.
And you want to make sure
that the cid there
is your client ID.
And that's going to add that
extra layer of security--
to know that on the round trip
of that flow, what's coming
back is what's actually intended
for you from Google.
And more information about how
to do to each of those steps--
it's actually really
straightforward--
is in our documentation.
But this user ID is what I'm
going to use to indicate this
user in my user database.
Maybe I have a local
ID, which is great.
And I use that in my
URLs or whatever.
But in that ID, I associate that
with their Google+ ID.
So when they hit this button,
I learn that--
I hit my user database for my
website, so that this is the
person I know from Google+.
And then I get back my local
user ID and all their
information.
And I can do that just as easily
on the website as I can
from mobile.
So we're going to look at it
first on web, just a demo of
how this works.
And then we're going to
look at it on mobile.
And of course, I'll
make this source
available for you later.
All right, so first
with the web.
One of these browsers--
here we are.
So I threw together this really
quick web page that
first asks me to sign in
with Google+, which
I'm going to do.
And that allows me
to set a quote.
"Improve life through science
and art." Cool.
And I'm going to submit that--
really simple.
What's happening here behind
the scenes is I hit
that Sign In button.
I get the user's ID.
And then the user
sets a quote.
And I send that to my
user database, both
the ID and the quote.
And it's associating the
ID and the quote.
Now I'm going to go over to
mobile here, and load up my
application.
So I actually took the starter
app, pulled out all the stuff,
kept the sign in and a call
to my customized API--
where I send the user ID,
and I get back a quote.
I hope it works.
I'm going to sign in again
with Captain Timothy.
We've got that.
Signed in.
And there's my quote.
Right?
Really straightforward,
end to end.
This demo would take you about
an hour to build by just
pulling down the starter apps
and pushing the data out--
maybe a few more minutes if
you have to build a little
custom API that I did
for the quote.
So we've covered a
lot of topics.
We've talked all the way through
an overview, a review
of the flow of Google+
History, through to
activities in depth.
And we've also covered errors,
OAuth, and mobile.
And finally, we looked at
using it for login.
So you can see, at the end
of the day, there's
a lot to this API.
But remember, the intention here
is to allow the user to
communicate online better, by
giving them the capability to
save moments privately to their
Google+ History and then
to optionally share them
with whom they want.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
do questions.
Oh, and I have stickers
to give away.
It's the end of the day.
I need to give them all away.
So maybe I'll do that
right after.
But those who ask questions
get more, which is good,
because Gerwin always
needs more stickers.
AUDIENCE: So actually, just
a short question first.
Is this Last.fm functionality
available to those who signed
up for the preview?
Because I checked the
Last.fm page, and I
didn't find the settings.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It is not.
AUDIENCE: It is not.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So in this
developer preview, you're
developing your own
application.
You're not testing other
company's applications.
That said, if you want
developers in your team to
test your own application,
you can do that.
And you can grant them access.
But there's two things
restricting--
one, Last.fm just gave
me the password.
And two is that there's an
API restriction, right?
So you're only going
to be able to make
1,000 queries per day.
It's not quite enough to
open it up to anybody.
It's really, truly just
a developer preview.
AUDIENCE: And the second
question was, how about
moments for Google+ pages
as opposed to profiles?
Because I think that's going to
be an interesting use case.
Especially since we have the
possibility to display the
moments on your profile
or on your blast
page on this [? new ?]
[? app ?].
So I think that would be an
interesting addition for some
pages, because they could have
some news feed where they just
have some items.
They have some favorites which
they want to show so that they
don't get lost in the stream.
But I guess that's the problem
with the OAuth workflow,
because that's the same with
Hangout apps, which you can't
use because of the
OAuth workflow.
But I think that's something
that's going to be
interesting.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, Tim.
I'm curious, because I think
about the point of this is
taking the activity that
[INAUDIBLE] person are doing
on the websites--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Will--
for everybody out there
in the internets--
Will asked for an example.
He used many more words, but
he asked for an example.
AUDIENCE: So my point is, you
could use the two to make
favorites of different stuff and
just share those favorites
in your moment step.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think I hear
what Gerwin's asking for is
for pages also to have the
ability to share, or to
collect moments and then share
them specifically.
Let's talk more about
this afterwards.
Thank you for the feedback.
Any other questions?
Oh, over here.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
embed HTML in the result
field, so that besides the link
to the page, that you
could put other links in the
description part of the schema
markup that goes at the bottom
half of the share?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I do not believe
so, but I'm not 100%
percent sure about that.
You can ask that on the
discussion forum, and we can
dig into that.
So far, we've been
looking at it--
most of the time we've wanted
to just sort of keep that
plain text, so it
hasn't come up.
But I would love to dig
more deeply into your
[? prospects. ?]
AUDIENCE: Right, so one use
case is [? plussing ?] the
profiles of other
Google+ users.
So from a Hangout that you did
some activity, you could post
that to your History.
But be able to tag the other
people that were in that
Hangout with you, which you
can do through the profile
link markups.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, cool.
Thanks for the feedback.
Oh, more questions.
I love this.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering will you
possibly in the future open
access to the History
to developers?
For example, as a use case--
I don't know if other
third parties do it
or Google does this.
For example, a couple of years
from now, send up snippets of
what you might have done this
day, or the most important
stuff you did this day five
years ago, or the photos you
took, or the events
you attended.
So I don't know if this could be
handled by Google or third
parties, which would have access
to the History API.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So what you're
asking for is read access to
moments that have
been written.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Thanks for the feedback.
AUDIENCE: Oh, just me?
Is there a way to undo the
moment, ie, delete the moment
which was accidentally
created?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great question.
So if you--
and we'll cover this in more
detail in the documentation--
right now, you can update it.
But there's no way to fully
remove a moment
once it's been written.
AUDIENCE: And by updating, you
just update the content on the
URL, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Correct.
AUDIENCE: And if I insert
it, it will just
pull the new data.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Also users
can delete their moments.
So whereas the site will just
write moments, the user can
actually go into the UI.
And right by that Share button
that you saw under the
triangle, you can click that
and delete the moment.
AUDIENCE: So what if the site
creates 1,000 moments?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You could
delete all of them.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
David's feeding me
answers here.
There is an option to delete
all the moments
from a certain source.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
Sorry, that was like--
what?
I'm not the only one with
caffeine, am I?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So for moments right
now-- they're being treated as
individual moments that belong
to a particular user.
And therefore that user allows
them to go public, basically.
But for a Hangout, a moment
could involve several
different people.
I know that's not really handled
right now, but if you
were in a Hangout with five
other people, you're playing a
game, and you want to have
a moment in that game--
I've had this conversation
with a few people.
And the first issue that gets
brought up is that there's a
bit of a privacy issue there,
because you're sharing a
moment that isn't just
your moment.
You're sharing other people's
involvement in that moment.
Is there any thought around
whether you should just be
allowed to do that?
Or whether you will have some
sort of process where
everybody can vet it or check
it, approve it, or if you can
approve it going in?
I recognize that my face will be
used, and blah, blah, blah,
kind of thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great question.
And actually, David Glazer has
just stood up to a microphone.
So of course, I'll
defer to him.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah, I mostly
want to say that that is a
great question.
We have talked about
exactly that.
And we don't have
the full answer.
So as you are working through
what could you do with the
History API, get those
conversations
going in the forum.
We like that idea.
But we also recognize the
challenges you introduced,
because there's a ton of power
in how personal History is,
and how private and how much
I, as a user, know
that this is mine.
I expect users will have the
kind of relationship with
their History that they would
have with a private diary or a
private journal, where it would
feel really wrong for
someone else to have
written into it.
At the same time, many of the
most important moments in my
life are shared moments.
A lot of the important things I
do, I do with other people I
care about.
So there is an answer here.
AUDIENCE: It's the social
medium, isn't it?
DAVID GLAZER: Yes.
Yeah.
So we're looking for
the right answer.
One of our metaphors that we're
trying to ride on is how
you can tag people in photos.
And we're trying to
see if that works.
Because I take a picture that
has four of us in it, and I
tag them in those flows there.
So really my answer is keep
this conversation going.
Work through it.
Think through specific cases.
And say, boy, could I do this?
The person who asked earlier
about putting a profile markup
in a moment was really getting
at the same use case.
We think it's an interesting
use case.
AUDIENCE: We work together.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And to reiterate
that-- thank you
very much, David-- is the
discussion forum is linked
from our documentation.
We're very active in there.
And it is an early developer
preview.
This is just the right time to
really be raising a lot of
these tough questions
and trying to push
this product forward.
AUDIENCE: This is a little bit
of an extension to this--
because what do we want
to share here?
I understand that sometimes you
want these moments to be
private, but I listen to
some music, maybe my
friends or my Circles.
So maybe I want to listen to the
same music that other in
my Circle listens to.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, so
it's a great use case.
And what you can
do now today--
and play around with
this in the
developer UI in the product--
you'll be able to set some
moments from some sources as
visible on your Moments tab.
So it's not creating a post and
sending them to everybody.
But maybe you want your listens
on Last.fm visible to
your music friends.
AUDIENCE: But I'd have to
do this manually, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You as the user
would make the choice.
AUDIENCE: Also, announced at
the developer preview--
I understand that you don't have
any dates, but I'm very
excited on using this.
And we have cases where
we want to do
this right now, actually.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool.
AUDIENCE: But release dates?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We don't have
any dates right now.
AUDIENCE: Nothing?
The year?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We don't have
any dates right now.
But thank you, and please
do get started.
AUDIENCE: We will.
JOSEPH: And keep beating
us up until we launch.
I also work on History.
And it's a preview partly
because we think we need to
build more stuff.
And partly because we want to
get developers actually
putting content in there so when
we can open up, there's
more stuff.
But when you really feel like
it's good enough, and we're
just being dumb by not opening
it up, as opposed to it's a
good thing for all of us that
we're continuing to work on
it, make sure you say
that loud and clear.
Because that will obviously
influence our choice.
This is one of those things--
we could hold longer or less
long, and there's trade offs.
So it's good to have
input on that.
AUDIENCE: Now, I can't say for
the quality of the API, if it
works and everything, but
from the overview, it
looks good for me.
Of course, I don't
have all the--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're ready.
AUDIENCE: --details
in the UI, but--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We hear that.
Thank you.
JOSEPH: And well, on things like
not knowing what to do
with the social stuff-- those
are the kinds of things we
have to gnarl on and say, is
that something we need to
figure out before
we open it up?
Or can we just add that later?
And we really don't
know right now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool, thank
you for the question.
And thank you, Joseph.
We've got a couple more.
Hi, John.
AUDIENCE: So maybe you covered
this this morning, but did the
different moments--
you have the different types,
the listen and the watch-type
events-- do they have different
meaning within the
Google+ application context?
Do they do something different
on the page?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So right now,
you'll notice that the moments
look a little bit different,
mostly on how
we phrase what happened.
And there could be more that
we could do there.
But right now, you'll just see
that differ a little bit.
And again, the key difference
is how we display it.
AUDIENCE: So one issue
comes up with these--
I don't want to say these
types of systems.
I don't want to sandbox it.
But are you planning for more
types of moments, if they have
that special meaning, if there's
something more to
them, planning for more types?
And if so, is there a process
to suggest types, vet types,
develop or create types?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, we
would love to know what
types should be added.
And we have an issue tracker set
up on our documentation.
Go to that issue tracker.
Say, I want this
type, and why.
AUDIENCE: So the API at present
doesn't look like it's
well-structured to handle
lots of different types.
It looks like it's a
very small set of
well-structured types.
I mean, you could eventually
have a lot.
But it's because it's part of
the call, as opposed to, say,
part of one of the tokens that
you're passing in or
something like that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I
actually disagree.
What we ended up doing is we
went with schema.org markup.
And what we transmit in the
payload at moment write time
is jsonified schema.org
markup.
And what you mark up
on the page is,
again, schema.org markup.
Now, if you look at schema.org,
it scales very
well to many, many,
many types.
In fact, I think you can even
mark up a volcano if you want,
with a postal address
and everything.
AUDIENCE: You could definitely
mark it up.
But your actual API list has the
name of the moment in it,
like a Buy moment or
a Listen moment.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So but how you
encode that is the URI
specifying that particular
type.
So right now, those are the
only ones that we accept.
And most of those have
schema.org URLs.
But as we accept more, we can
probably just pick that URL
from schema.org.
And if necessary, we can talk
about adding in new types in
schema.org.
And also, we can cover
generic types.
So if it's not on the list and
we don't add it in later, you
can try and fit it under, say,
AddActivity or ViewActivity or
CreateActivity, which all can
cover several very more
specific type of activities.
AUDIENCE: So that issue of
overlap is also the last thing
I was going to bring up, which
is, as you add those things--
and even with what you've got
now, there's often overlap
issues where people might
disagree as to what type of
moment it is.
I'm sensing that you guys are
aware of these issues, but it
doesn't sound like you've
worked through
them very much yet.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
we're still in
early developer preview.
I'll stop there, actually.
It looks like David
is itching to add
something in here as well.
DAVID GLAZER: Just that--
you're right.
We haven't worked them through
all the way, which is why we
started with a--
we picked a vocabulary to start
with that we wanted to
be big enough to get the idea
across of hey, we're going for
different kinds.
And we have the ability to do
different types of rendering
and different types
of metadata.
But no bigger than to
get the idea across.
So as Timothy said, there is a
link in the documentation.
Specifically, it's right under
the list of nine moments.
It says, Submit a request
for a new type.
Because we want to
look at that.
And I've had a couple
of good hallway
conversations about this.
There's a tension between
the complete, open-ended
possibility, where each
individual action gets to be
as well-defined as you want,
but you lose the ability to
sort of cluster and categorize
and think about my life in
organized chunks.
Or too constrained, where
everything gets fit into a
one-size-fits-all--
the equivalent of "add thing,"
which is not very useful.
So we want to look at the
specific requests that you
have, saying, I want a
verb that does this.
Because in my application, it
would be a perfect fit for.
And we want to look
at a set of those.
And this is just my gut.
My gut is we have
nine right now.
At launch, we should have
two to three times that.
That's my gut.
Not 10, but not just
a couple more.
But I could be off by a
factor of two there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thanks, guys.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you
Any final questions?
Well, OK.
Check out that URL if you want
to take a look at the other
sessions, either the Getting
Started or the Code Lab, which
we'll be doing in a room a few
doors down tomorrow morning.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]